un
autre panel ce soit à martin biron
michel david et christian duffau bonsoir
à vous trois voix mais commençons avec
cette petite surprise là le ministre de
la santé christian dubé vraiment qui est
alice d'une attaque frontale envers les
syndicats on trouve des infirmières en
disant écoutez les primes là c'est pas
pour les déléguées syndicales elles sont
en train d'essayer de le mettre là mais
là dessus ça ralentit le recrutement ça
ralentit le processus évidemment les
éphémères était pas content martin
comment vous l'expliquez cette attaque
là c'est sûr qu'entre le gouvernement et
les syndicats c'est pas mal faire sur
faire les syndicats en général depuis 50
ans au l'habitude de jouer livre c'est à
dire la convention collective mur à mur
et le gouvernement veut faire des choses
différemment et il veut renforcer
différents postes d'emploi alors il les
attaque de front ils les isole en disant
bon bain les infirmières
c'est toujours nos anges gardiens mais
nos syndicats commencent à étirer
l'élastique pas mal fort alors c'est eux
qui ont le mauvais rôle ce soir alors
qu'elle se défendent en disant baisse
était pas tout à fait sa
version existe jamais été question sur
dans nos négociations à michel là dessus
écoutez depuis le début de la pandémie
on sent que l'exaspération de monsieur
legault monte d'un mois à l'autre il ya
eu toute la question là des offres
différenciées dans le secteur public qui
l'empêchait d'offrir des augmentations
plus importantes à des acteurs clés dans
durant la pandémie libre est posée aux
bénéficiaires dont les infirmières
maintenant alors disons monsieur legault
au départ c'est pas un grand
syndicaliste
mais ce qui s'est passé au cours des
derniers mois le japon cela un peu
exaspéré et là
il faut dire que le plan de rétention ou
de rappel de jean d'infirmières surtout
dans le réseau de la santé donne déjà
pas des bons résultats alors là à voir
un obstacle de plus
ça lui sert à la fois pas de prétextes
mais il ya trouvé un bouc émissaire mais
la vérité est que son plat difficultés à
fonctionner c'est ça c'est quoi c'est
notre collègue véronique prince qui
disait on en a recruté 864 et on en
cherche 5 mais elle vous voyez quand
même on est loin du score on est dans un
groupe aussi cherché tout de suite avec
un autre sujet que son jeu vous lancer
là dessus parce qu'on a vraiment un gros
agenda ce soit après beaucoup de sujets
partiel dans marie-victorin évidemment
là il n'y a pas ce qu'ils se libèrent de
ce que tu apprennes fourni est devenue
mairesse de longueuil ça serait une
occasion pour le chef du parti québécois
pour st pierre plamondon le tenter à
tout le moins de se faire élire ont su
que c'était un château-fort péquiste
mais les rythmes ans aujourd'hui
monsieur paul st pierre plamondon et
d'observer jeunes stratégie mais je peux
vous en parler de suite on va l'écouter
un petit extrait suivie d'une réaction
de françois nous on a une stratégie dans
l'art et victor et
ils m'ont dit de pas vous dire si vous
me posez la question j'ai bien noté
l'hésitation de psp j'aimerais d'abord
savoir si le chef du parti québécois
veut se présenter dans marie-victorin
avant de prendre une décision si on veut
ou non présenter un candidat dans marie
victorin
qu'est ce que vous comprenez de la
stratégie n'est pas simplement dont la
question les qui va pas nous dire s'il
va se présenter ou pas bah je vois sa
décision est prise encore beaucoup de
gens dit qu'on dise que pas le choix
vraiment de se présenter je pas d'accord
c'est un gros test pour lui de
leadership évidemment si gentille est
parce qu il est très gentil bailly va
aller au combat mais y'a pas grand chose
à gagner là-dedans il ya énormément à
perdre pourquoi irait-il à ce combat
leur gabriel l'a12 gaulle lui il n'y a
pas fait de cadeau à paul st pierre
plamondon n'ya pas il n'y a pas respecté
la tradition de pour présenter de
candidat contre monsieur plamondon donc
moi je trouve que c'est vraiment fort
pasqua de phares pour ça ira pas parce
que pour lui l'enjeu c'est l'élection
générale ces post élections partielles
las comme un piège tafer là mais je
convaincu beaucoup de commentateurs vos
arrières pas le choix il n'y a pas le
choix violent choix est pas obligé
pourquoi il réel sinon mail et puis s'il
va pas si maintenant le pq gagner ça
serait bon si le pq perd je serai pas
trop permissive qu'est-ce qui peut
gagner lui c'est une autre question
michel david vous en pensez quoi il peut
choisir le moindre mal je pense que ce
défilé
à terme ça causerait moins de dommages
que de se faire battre et dans marie
victor et les chansons que monsieur st
pierre plamondon se fasse battre bon
madame fournier avait gagné la
circonscription avec 500 et quelques
voix mais c'était déjà beaucoup moins
que les 3500 que bernard de rêver là va
gagner en 2014 et depuis ce temps là le
pq a continué à perdre des plumes et
ilakaka monte alors ses chances de
victoire sont minces mais là je pense
que ce qui peut ce qu'il doit considérer
monsieur plamondon c'est le monde aussi
la date à laquelle monsieur legault va
déclencher si il déclenchait tao bout de
l'échéance des six mois ça serait plus
facile pour monsieur st pierre plamondon
de dire écoutez il lui reste juste deux
trois semaines de session ça vaut pas à
peine joué à attendre la générale s'ils
déclenchent au tout début de la nouvelle
année là ça va devenir plus gênant de
dire je passe un tour alors il perd dans
les deux cas mais je pense qu'ils
perdraient moins à ne pas y aller
martine il serait pas en fait lui y
réfléchit manifestement en toi on n'a
pas la stratégie ce soit bien de hume
qui est prête à plonger c'est martine
ouellet qui est chef de nouveaux partis
qu'on voit pas souvent mais qui existe
qui s'appelle kim au québec qui se
présente comme un parti indépendantiste
et puis qui fait aussi de la lutte au
changement climatique une priorité il va
avoir pas mal de parties indépendantes
c'est ce qu'ils vont se présenter là en
fait quand on regarde le conte avec q
est-ce le pq martin ouellette climat et
le parti pour l'indépendance du québec
aussi que va présenter son son chef et
ils vont ils vont se piler sur les pieds
les indépendantistes dans cette
partielle là alors je peux comprendre
que ça va être risqué pour paul st
pierre plamondon de se présenter
rapidement à cette élection là surtout
que si la terre il va être extrêmement
affaibli pour l'élection générale je
pense pas que le parti québécois va
vraiment avoir le temps de se trouver un
autre chef mais ça démontre aussi qu en
a plus comptez sur au québec pour le
parti québécois et que la prochaine
élection va être passablement difficile
oui madame delà de lierre déjà elle
faisait d'ailleurs vous l'avez twitté
hier qu'elle serait prête à respecter
cet espèce de règle non écrite la ou les
parties laisse le champ libre à un autre
chef de parti pour qu'il puisse avoir sa
place à l'assemblée nationale donc elle
serait prête à ne pas présenter de
candidat pour le parti libéral
a quelque part elle le fait pour elle où
elle le fait pour faire une fleur qui
souvent passé merci mme basset deux
c'est plus facile de 5,6 c'est facile de
faire une offre comme ça quand à zéro
chance de gagner la circonscription tu
force les autres a tranché et toutes ne
peut en valeur c'est exactement ce
qu'elle a fait ça se fait c'est vrai que
ça se fait on l'a vu dans le passé de
laisser passer un chef mais dans ce cas
ci je pense pas que ça va se faire parce
que tu es seule chance de livrer une
bataille dans cette circonscription la
halle à l'ombre pandémique pour les
partis d'opposition ça a été difficile
alors cette partielle là ça va leur
permettre de se mettre en valeur alors
je pense qu'il va y avoir une course est
bon martin molette notamment qui veut
reprendre du service et grivois y avoir
visiblement une campagne bon alors on va
suivre ça on n'a pas la dette encore un
on comprend que c'est pas pour tout de
suite ce serait certainement pas venger
en vignes bas j'ai fait c'est ce que tu
as et le groupe
cesi c'est un gros test pour paul st
pierre plamondon on va voir jusqu'à quel
point il est capable de supporter la
pression parce qu'il va avoir beaucoup
de pression pour qu'ils y aillent ouais
ouais et iraizoz se faire poser la
question à chaque fois qu'ils se
présentent devant un micro aussi le fait
de faire durer le suspense comme ça
c'est tout pour relancer
toujours il peut il peut quand même
temps que l'élection est pas déclenchée
je me prononcerai pas mais aussitôt
cavale est forcément il devra prendre
des décisions bon alors on est en
attente de la du dévoilement de la
stratégie on va parler du pack alors
aujourd'hui on a vu celui qui le grand
patron là monsieur gaudreault
reconnaître en fait qui est vraiment une
crise de confiance envers cette
organisation la dir est mais c'est moi
trois ans en train de faire de l'
embauche on rehausse le niveau de
formation de nos enquêteurs on va voir
nos propres enquêteurs
réaction de ministre de sécurité
publique j'aime bien guilbeault on les
coûts tout de suite donnons leur une
chance de comment dire de pouvoir
utiliser de manière optimale et complète
les outils qu'on a enfin mis à leur
disposition à travers deux projets de
loi qu'on a fait adopter en moins de
trois ans on nomme des gens indépendants
pour faire un travail à la tête
d'institutions indépendantes ces gens là
c'est la responsabilité de faire
fonctionner les institutions nous notre
esprit moi ma responsabilité c'est de
leur donner outil c'est fait maintenant
moi aussi je peux particulièrement
patiente dans la vie donc le je pense
qu'il va falloir un moment donné où
c'est que ça évolue
donc il s'en est ce qu on a trois ans
pour attendre et leur donner une chance
pour rebâtir cette confiance il va
écouter pour le citoyen ordinaire mouche
aux citoyens ordinaires là dedans la
réputation de l'upac est tellement
attaché c'est pas juste le fait que le
pot livrer la marchandise c'est que le
fait du mal le fait des mauvaises choses
le monsieur gaudreault qui est quand
même là depuis 2010 9 ou 10 attendait en
moi je crois beaucoup au sujet pas de
solution mais je trouve que c'est
injuste un running gag les plus calmes
quand on parle aux gens où les gens sont
vraiment un peu écoeuré de ce don
qu'est-ce qu'il faut l'abolir pour la
fusionner avec la sortie de québec
changé l'on a c'est un peu comme le
nouveau co vous savez quand on avait
distillé d'avoir un nouveau coq mounir
venu au vieux coq a donc le problème est
là mais l'upa khl se sont inscrits à
terre quand comment autrement dit il
pourrait être positif et si monsieur
gaudreault était capable d'ici deux
trois ans de faire vraiment beaucoup
d'éclairs quelque chose d'extraordinaire
qui nous étonnerait tous mes sens aux
chevaux pauvres mots comme il peut reçu
bon la sphère de change maintenant
effectivement ça a été évoquée d'un
point de presse il a été questionné là
tu dis qu'il faut fermer monsieur
gaudron un changement de nom mais dans
les faits michel changer de nom
ça sert à quoi ben ça sera pas grand
chose effectivement si le
le produit ne s'améliore pas mais
d'autre part j'ai entendu madame ilbo
aujourd'hui dire de façon assez claire
ça ne l'intéressait pas alors je pense
je pense pas que ce soit à court terme
une option obligé je pense pas non plus
que madame guilbaud envie de se lancer
dans une réorganisation là d'ici
l'élection à la je pense bien que
monsieur vos deux roues disposent d'au
moins l'élection est probablement à un
an après l'élection pour faire ses
preuves il faudrait pas par contre qu il
yad autres bavures comme on en a vu
dernièrement que je pense au maire l'ex
maire de de terrebonne ça s'il fallait
encore qu'il ya du cafouillage
love vraiment ce serait plus récupérable
mais au moment où on se parle je pense
que l'upac a encore une chance mais
c'est la dernière oui comme on parle
effectivement des déboires avec le
procès de l'ex maire à leur procès on
rappelle aux téléspectateurs qui a
complètement déraillé huard est
procédure la juge qui eut des mots
extrêmement durs envers celui qu'il
numéro 2 celui qui travaillait de pelle
avec monsieur hugo drôle qui mettent des
laitages l'anis latif c'est ça écoutez
là je parlais de il y avait eu là dedans
dès la présentation trompeuse des propos
mal ce mensonge et à parler de
malhonnêteté en fait qu'on parle de
crise de confiance la boisson ne juge
que rien fait pour aider bien sûr il y
avait cet éléphant dans la pièce comme
on le dit à pendant ce point de presse
martin la blanquette ma chérie qui est
en train de battre des records de
longueur le ici monsieur gaudreault il
continue à s'accrocher et dit non non
écouter on elle continue elle est
compliquée les fuites ça ne va pas aider
mais il reste que sk encore quelqu'un
dans la pièce qui croit cette enquête le
mas lui visiblement l'air à y croire
mais je m'en suis dire une petite chose
sûre sur le procès justement avortée du
maire de lens et maire de terrebonne
parce qu'il ya quand même deux une pac
il ya l'upac robert lafrenière et là on
a eu les les accusations de nathalie
normandeau guy ouellette député tout ça
est tombé mais ce qui est arrivé avec
l'ancien maire de terrebonne ses sous
frédérick gaudreau alors ça c'est la
nouvelle administration et la dernière
fois qu'on a vu un procès avorté parce
que les policiers avaient mal fait leur
travail il avait caché de la preuve vous
planter de la preuve moi mon souvenir
ces procès des frères matticks dans les
années 90 que déboucher sur une enquête
publique l'enquète la commission
denquête poitras sur le travail des
enquêteurs de la sûreté du québec alors
le gouvernement sans état si bien tiré
parce qu'il y avait autre chose dans
l'actualité mais peut-être que le
gouvernement devrait se garde des sceaux
d'un petit peu plus proche du peuple
mais vous avez vu le recul compris
monsieur gaudreault pendant le point de
presse dans un mois je vais pas trop de
parler de sol parce que il est possible
que le dpcp aille en appel là dessus
dont il semblait même avoir une certaine
confiance que ça pourrait redémarrer ce
procès
alessi que sa maman je trouve que l'upac
a tellement déçu on veut tellement cru
un moment donné qui ont une marge de
manoeuvre énorme on a appris des abus
qui nous étonnerait beaucoup de gens en
fait qui normalement sont sont honnêtes
sont intègres donc c'est pour ça que je
trouve que ce climat j'ai pas tout le
mais en termes de relations publiques
d'image cette institution là c'est bien
beau les belles paroles de monsieur
gaudreault sa bonne foi mais il faut se
souvenir de ce que c'était les paccots
moment donné ça comme les chevalier sans
peur et sans reproche on avait le goût
d'y croire ils ont 10 donc moi moi
personnellement je crois plus j'y
croyais puppy macherez y croyez vous à
cette enquête non c'est tellement
compliqué ces choses là marc tienne je
les admire beaucoup puis même chez eux
il se débat elle dans les idées mais
pensez-vous plasturgie n'a intéressé
mais ma chérie c'est vraiment commencé
en fait depuis le même dit lui-même
l'oeil a dit tous les éléments d'enquêté
ont été ont fuité
personnes qui sont sous enquête
ça fait plus de 7,1 qu'une enquête
criminelle sur leurs têtes pointues leur
tête et ça inclut le lancer premier
ministre jean charest lui même alors il
s'agissait pas cessé c'est quand même
difficile à michel sur ma chérie ben ça
peut pas durer éternellement peut-être
le second d'euros croate il est
peut-être celle raison qui a un format
aux solutions que là
l'upac peu entretenues par rien que
l'upac d'ailleurs mais encore faut-il
arriver à une démonstration qui feraient
les titres entre la route devant les
tribunaux et si j'y arrive pas on peut
pas continuer encore comme ça pendant
des années moi je pense que d'ici d'ici
un an si on est pauvre on n'a pas réussi
à présenter quelque chose de solide il
va falloir abandonner arrêté le suspect
d'une certaine façon bon air canada
alors air canada soudainement miracle le
chef de la direction michael rousseau a
trouvé une place dans son agenda pour
suivre des cours de français bonjour des
cours des cours personnel intensif
absolument quand c'est intensif ça prend
quand même pas mal de place dans une
journée
michel est ce que est ce que tout ça
finalement en bout de ligne va avoir eu
du bon parce que ça a dévoilé un
problème mais vraiment là à la haute
direction de air canada est le message
que sans moi on trouve pas à tous les
employés bah on va devoir assez
rapidement d'alcool de monsieur rousseau
j'imagine qu'ils vont essayer dans son
prochain discours de nous impressionner
avec son français on pourra juger sur
pièce mais au-delà de ça et si c'est le
fonctionnement d'air canada qui est un
problème
récurrent depuis depuis sa création la
ddt et d'une fois à l'autre ça
s'améliore pas c'est le champion toutes
catégories des plaintes comme celle
officielle et on va voir sur le terrain
chacun a sa petite histoire à raconter
sur l'unilinguisme anglais à air canada
mais les progrès de vote devront venir
parce que là c'est très bien madame
freeland attention le conseil
d'administration mais ce sont vous et
moi et tous les francophones qui vont
prendre l'avion qui vont qu'ils vont
pouvoir juger et christine laissue vous
avez écrit une chronique dans la presse
aujourd'hui c'est un sujet qui va
vraiment me chercher oui c'est vrai
comme beaucoup d'autres je pense que
c'est curieux de voir monsieur rousseau
suivre des cours de français pour
l'image mais on va voir si capable de
parler français il n'y a pas une
obligation de moyens à une obligation de
résultat mais monsieur beaucoup de
francophones qui se contentent d'assez
peu mais je trouve c'est beaucoup plus
large
non c'est beaucoup plus large qui air
canada parce que comme l'avait écrit
stéphanie grammond dans la presse ce qui
était plus choquant au fond que le
discours en anglais seulement monsieur
rousseau s'est fait que les 320
personnes qui ont de la chambre de
commerce du montréal métropolitain
applaudi unanimement y en a pas un qui
aurait agi ça fait ressortir que le
problème c'est en partie des
francophones qui sont qui doivent être
servile qui sont dénaturés qui peuvent
être assimilés un défaitiste c'est
beaucoup plus large que ce soit une très
bonne doivent in the il nous fait un
cadeau monsieur rousseau parce qu'il
révèle quelque chose qui existe est mais
c'est ça dépassait requins meurent parce
quelqu'un à lyon paul choix mettez vous
à leur place ce gloss un manque de
jugement grossier je pas sûr qu'un grand
avenir à air canada il ya tellement
rapport avec le français qui quasiment
pathologique
bon là ils suivent ses cours de français
mandroux à bien l'opération de relations
publiques même beaucoup de francophones
qui se contentent de sang et or il s'est
excusé y apprend le français on passe à
autre chose ne faut pas passer à autre
chose c'est trop important merci mme
faudrait que maintenant sa prime de
rendement à dépendre sa qualité de
français là on a rajouté quelque chose
du côté du site web et je pense que
c'est la moindre des choses que le
conseil d'administration face c'est sans
son travail mais aussi au québec je
pense qu démunis nani l'idée
c'est très difficile à accepter mais
quand on ouvre les quotidiens nationaux
anglophone l'autre mail mais nous
n'achetons au poste et on semble dire
qu'il n'ya pas trop de problème à ce que
les pdg des entreprises pas au juste
anglais
ça m'amène ailleurs c'est un même à dire
que ces entreprises qui ont des fonds
publics par exemple devrait avoir des
obligations de résultat est redevable
aux citoyens et à leur culture que ce
soit on a vécu aussi des moments très
difficiles avec bombardier pour toute
autre raison le cpo culturel mais c'est
un peu la même chose pour air canada ils
ont des comptes à rendre aux citoyens et
ils doivent le faire et on va voir ce
monsieur rousseau voltaire parce
qu'actuellement on est juste dans
l'opération de relations publiques oui à
écouter lyon réponse tellement vu par la
lettre de madame plaindre quand même
l'impression qu'elle est la liste de
riposte était d'échapper à disque et moi
je trouve ça attire l'attention sur le
fait que la défense du français ne sais
pas où je suis mangerai marais de copies
des billets sur les os et tous les
francophones en position d'autorité qui
doivent se tenir debout davantage parce
que monsieur michel leblanc le reste que
monsieur michel leblanc sont possibles
mais qu'on voit qu'on reçoit vraiment
sait comment ça se fait que mais
on a plus de temps qu'ancien mais on a
très bien compris j'invite les gens à
laisser votre chronique dans la presse
vous expliquer tout ça merci à vous
trois merci merci à mes chers écrit ça
on va voir au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh